j'ai une direction qui m'a laissé le
champ libre pour monter un projet
pédagogique autour du street art et des
arts urbains et c'est la voie d'entrée
pour mes cours auprès des élèves
et c'est vrai qu'on a un peu occupé
l'espace en sous sol de manière ordonnée
régulière est totale on va aller visiter
les sous-sols
j'avais même suivre
[Musique]
sincère de vestiaire un prof de sport
qui après partie
je tape dur aux mans
dans cette pièce sont trouve une
illusion d'optique qui s'appelle une
anamorphose la morpho c'est un visuel
une image qui n'est visible comme
l'artiste où les artistes en
l'occurrence on souhaitait qu'elle
apparaisse dans sa manière définitive
que depuis un point de vue particulier
et c'est une photo de classe
photo de la classe qui a réalisé fait
partie du projet pédagogique d'essayer
d'utiliser les techniques applicables en
entreprise ou dans leur métier dans mon
cours d'arts plastiques ou d'arts
appliqués cette petite salle c'est une
salle qu'on a choisi de peindre en
lumière fluo pour que quand on apporte
le petit canon de lumière noire sa façon
[Musique]
sauf dans la salle de musculation du cfa
donc c'est les filles de le sbf qu'on
portait le maillot bleu elles sont
venues signer à côté de leurs portraits
de leur nom ce qui valorise vraiment le
travail des élèves ils en sont très
fiers et portes ouvertes c'est toujours
l'occasion de valoriser un peu cet
espace est le travail des élèves
donc effectivement on ajoute à cet
espace des lumières c'est le collectif
spotlight est mon ami philippe vuillemin
qui qui chaque année me prête le
matériel et rend cet espace un peu
magique
c'est l'essentiel de leur montrer que
l'art peut s'adresser à eux et qu'ils
peuvent en est destinataire en tant que
spectateur en tant qu'acteur et comme je
dis aux chocolatiers
vous avez tous les mêmes recettes donc
ce qui fait qu'on va choisir un plutôt
que l'autre c'est sa créativité